a government white paper on social care
was released this week promising to
spend more than five billion pounds over
three years boris johnson's failed to
end the often crippling builds faced by
many in old age announcing a cap on care
costs for adults in england from october
2023
so what could this mean for the social
care sector
the chief executive of the four seasons
healthcare group jeremy richardson
is with us good morning mr richardson um
how worried is the care sector about uh
the facing a winter crisis with omicron
and everything else
morning trevor i think the secretary is
really worried at the moment not
necessarily because of the threat faced
by omicron but because of the bigger
challenges the wider issues that we've
got which are long term and not just in
the moment
so you think that there could well be a
winter crisis um
as bad as it was last winter
well look i don't think the sector is
going to collapse tomorrow but it's
gradually falling over and the problem
is that incrementally you're seeing a
decline in the quality of services so so
if we look at the social care reform
that's just been announced
you know i applaud the intent that the
government has undertaken because they
are the first government in many decades
to try to tackle the problem
the issue is that the execution is
really disappointing somebody last week
described it as an underpowered saloon
car when what's required is a formula
one racing car and i think that's
probably quite apt
i want to come to the social care
reforms in a second but uh before we do
that can i just ask you about the impact
of the government's mandate uh that all
staff should be jabbed i know that you
and
some of your colleagues were concerned
that this would have an impact on staff
numbers what do you know so far
well look i've been really clear and
i've said i didn't think that mandating
the vaccine was the right thing to do
and i still think that that's the case
and unfortunately that ship has now
sailed um
we have lost about 200 staff members so
that's 200 really hard working members
of team who are providing care to our
residents on the day today
if i may ask
200 people we think have left the
business so 49 people left on the 11th
of november so those were the people
that we had to dismiss but then you've
got the title of what number what's what
is your workforce so we have 12 and a
half thousand team members 49 left on
the final day but we estimate that 200
left in the run-up so in total we've
lost about 1.6 of our workforce and what
you've got to bear in mind is that at
the time that we had to get rid of those
people we already had 95 of our team
fully vaccinated double jabbed providing
protection to themselves and also to the
residents so i think in a situation like
that what you have to do is weigh up
relative risk and the greater risk to my
residents today is that i don't have
enough team members to look after them
and provide really good quality care
than the risk presented by transmission
of the virus itself
so let's talk about the social care
reform to see whether
what the government's brought forward
might help
to
deal with that risk from what you said
earlier on uh you don't think much much
of it uh it clearly didn't meet your
expectations
well no i mean as i say i applaud the
intent so so the prime minister has
stood up and he's told the public that
the social care issues are going to be
solved and if you're a member of the
public then you rightly believe that the
problem has been sold because that's
what the prime minister has told you
that the problem is that all that's been
announced is a short-term funding plan
for the nhs so 36 billion pounds is
going to be raised over the next three
years
31.6 billion of that is going into the
nhs so only 5.4 billion is going into
social care that's 1.8 billion a year
and it's widely accepted by all experts
that the sector needs between seven to
ten billion a year just to stand still
so unfortunately if you're going to
announce that you're fixing social care
don't just fund the nhs there isn't
enough funding going into the sector
that's one of the problems
and the second issue is that it's not
tackling today's issues the money that
we are going to receive in the bulk is
coming in three years time and that's
assuming that the nhs choose to hand it
back over at that stage
uh if i may i when i spoke to mr sunak
some weeks ago about this his argument
was that you couldn't you couldn't spend
that money tomorrow and what you needed
to do was to build it up so that in
three years time you're getting the the
bulk of it and that over time that that
number would build up um
did you accept that argument
no of course i don't i mean that's a
really convenient thing for him to say
because that it allows him to justify
not putting the funding into social care
today that it really needs
so so no i absolutely disagree with that
the fundamental issue here is that the
true cost of care so what it costs to
look after people safely and to provide
them with a really good quality of life
is not provided by the local authorities
so if additional funding came into the
sector now what you would see is an
increase in the average weekly fee
provided by local authorities and i
absolutely could spend that money
because the first thing i do is i'd
start to pay the team who are working so
hard in our homes what they're really
worth at the moment is very difficult
for us to do that because our revenues
are capped by local authorities which in
turn are capped by the lack of funding
provided by central government
i mean all round it sounds like uh you
are really rather despairing
both of the current situation
and also the impact of the government's
uh
plans as published in in their white
paper
well look i'm not despairing because we
are very fortunate at both as a company
and as a country that we have so many
phenomenally hard-working people in
social care i'm despairing beca but then
i am despairing in the context of the
finances because i don't think we've
solved the issues
and we will simply continue to see a
deterioration and gradual erosion if
we're not careful of the services that
we're able to deliver to people and i
think we have to ask ourselves as a
country you know what is it that's
important to us do we want to give our
elderly people dignity and quality of
life in their old age or do we want to
simply ignore them and i think the risk
is that unless we put proper funding
into the sector unless we really grapple
with the issue then we're just going to
see a slow deterioration of the quality
of service we provide and i'm more i
don't think that's morally right i think
we we owe it to our elderly people to
provide the best quality of care that we
possibly can
thank you very much indeed for your time
this morning uh mr richardson
thank you very much